we watched the movie eternals again and
one question popped into our minds how
long does it generally take for a
celestial to be born or for the
emergence to take place once the
celestial seed is inside a host planet
so in the mcu a celestial seed was
placed inside the earth 7 000 years ago
in the past but why did it take so long
for it to emerge and how did it grow
let's discuss everything about them in
detail in this video their origins
motives and life cycle as well as powers
so subscribe if you haven't already and
now let's do this thing
their origins and motives one begs the
question how did they come to be
since they were here even before the
universe began and even before the
infinity stones were created the
celestials are the universe's oldest
race they were present long before the
birth of creation and were responsible
for bringing planets and life forms from
all around the universe they used their
boundless cosmic power to create planet
stars and life forms as well as bringing
light into the universe and stop the
darkness from overcoming everything else
they seeded planets with nasa and
celestial seeds in order to create more
celestials and expand the bounds of life
in the universe they are not evil nor
good but just indifferent to the lives
of mortals and even gods their sole
purpose was clockwork to create more of
themselves so that they can create life
and stars so that they would be in turn
host for more emerging celestials this
also shows that celestials are asexual
in nature and are born out of created
seeds they usually need host planets
with an exception ego who didn't have
that he in fact became a planet quite
the opposite they can also reproduce
with models giving life to celestial
hybrids as in the case of star-lord
peter quill
so their appearance let's talk a little
bit on this before going to their life
cycle the celestials appear to have a
humanoid appearance their bodies appear
to have skeletal and neurological
aspects that were identical to humans
but on a planetary or even a bigger
scale when compared to a fully grown
celestial a human-sized eternal barely
registered as particles of dust for
example one servered head of a celestial
called nowhere is huge enough to house a
mining colony and it contains enough
extractable minerals to keep it running
for decades and even centuries for that
matter even though esau and the searcher
resembles the other celestial's
appearance his height and stature
however are shown to be enormously
smaller even though it's the size of a
mountain
ego on the other hand was of a planetary
scale and although he did have a human
avatar but that's about it his real self
is the entire planet he consciously
formed over millions of years
so now we come to the celestial life
cycle we can most definitely say that a
celestial is biologically immortal and
cannot die from old age that is if time
even has any effect on them but they can
be killed or they can die from other
means as we can see in the cases of ego
being killed by the guardians of the
galaxy nowhere by someone maybe null the
god of the symbiotes and then timoth in
the movie eternals by the eternals
themselves so we have quite a bit to
unravel here the celestials as seen in
the eternals were different from the
likes of ego but not as much as you
think a celestial's general appearance
and life would change in accordance to
how they were nurtured in their early
life stages let's see the life cycle of
them and then talk about ego after that
so from seed to emergence the normal
celestial life cycle takes millenniums
many millennia to complete irishman the
judge decreed that every few million
years some celestials must be born after
being seeded inside the planet the
celestial grows feeding on three things
one the innate cosmic energy that they
were designed to possess
two it feeds on the energy within the
core of the planet and also the minerals
within it the hotter it is and the more
dense the raw materials is present the
faster it would grow physically and
thirdly the most important part it needs
a massive amount of intelligence to grow
mentally in order for it to be ready to
come out and harness the cosmic energies
so let's talk about the last one the
third criteria uh celestial needs
sentient life forms for it to mature and
learn feeding off of the sentient energy
as per real life estimates since 10000
bc there have been around 100 billion
humans that have ever lived and maybe
this is the number needed for a
celestial to mature and emerge
but there is one more important point to
consider the usage of the infinity
stones so even though thanos wiping out
half the population of the universe
might have delayed the emergence
it would have just taken away just a
tiny bit of the time frame as compared
to the cosmic scale the population would
have redoubled again in a span of 50 to
100 years and it's back to square one
and when these infinity stones were used
a second time during end game it created
a huge surge of cosmic energy that gave
the necessary boost for the emergence of
timur and maybe others as well across
the universe
when a celestial is born a massive
armored humanoid erupts from its planet
in a cataclysmic explosion but then
again tiamat's birth was rather peaceful
if you would compare the first scene of
the celestial's emergence as shown by
arsham and tiamat's emergence maybe he
was reluctant and hence granted the
energy to the eternals in the form of
the unimine to kill himself in order to
save the billions of humans that ajax
the leader of the eternals once stated
that they were special even in the
comics tiemoue always had an affinity
towards humans and even sided with them
once in a while even defying the fulcrum
so enough about that now we come to
ego's case we think that ego like the
others was born out of a celestial scene
but the difference here is that ego
never found a host planet to mature in
as stated by himself when he first
became conscious he was all alone and
over millions of years he harnessed the
cosmic energies learned by himself and
grew into a planet in comparison to this
the other celestials had the massive
advantage of being inside a planet's
core feeding off on the minerals and the
heat and also transforming themselves
into humanoid beings as a reflection of
them feeding on the sentient humanoid
intelligences they were never alone they
matured faster in the time frame of
several thousand years as compared to
ego who took millions of years to do the
same and he became a planet in
appearance because that's all he knew
and with limited access to cosmic magic
since there was no sentient energy for
him to learn from
nevertheless the celestials can
manipulate matter and energy on a
massive scale and they are the
universe's most potent energy creators
although ego's case was different
the others their origins life cycle and
motives were all generally the same
so i hope you have enjoyed watching this
video with that we come to the end of it
so do hit that like button for support
and subscribe as well to be a part of
the mind cue family but most of all
smash the bell icon for regular updates
on new videos right here on this channel
till the next one take care fam